the Boltzmann machine I assume assume
that their machine learning to ya so
more machine learning for this siesta
time done I'm sure that you won't be
sleeping out so let's give an applause
to the guard opio Monty all right it's a
pleasure to be here today I want to talk
about some work I did together with my
my supervisors Giovanni and
Christopher's and two collaborators of
ours robbing in rob who are neuro
scientists so there'll be a bit of a
neuroscientist flavor to the talk and I
want to talk about modeling a text
corpus using deep Boltzmann machines in
Python of course so before I start a few
words about myself I'm a statistician
and I'm about to finish my PhD at
Imperial College London and my research
focuses mostly on computational
statistics and my research is driven
mostly by applications in neuroscience
in particular I do a lot of work with
functional MRI which is basically you
put someone in a scanner and you made
your blood flow in the brain and use
that as a proxy for sort of brain
activity and and well I use Python which
is why I'm here so today I'm going to
talk about a deep and restricted
Boltzmann machines and I was sort of
given instruction to what they are what
are their advantages disadvantages and
and so how do you train these models of
how would you do sort of model selection
on this and I want to try and motivate
all of this by an application to text
money so so before I sort of start
talking about or describing bolta
machines i thought i would do some
motivation into why you'd want to model
a text corpus so today or at this
conference we've seen examples of sort
of recommender systems or search engines
where you sort of have text as input I
need to try and model this text right so
there's tons of applications as to why
you'd want to model text but actually in
our work we had a very sort of specific
motivation and this was based on some
work we we did recently which we sort of
quite
provocatively named the automatic
neuroscientist so in a traditional fMRI
or neuro science experiment the way it
works is a neuroscientist will design a
task say tapping your fingers or
watching some videos and then you put
someone in the scanner and you observe
the the brain activations so the mapping
is going from task to M activations
right whereas what the neuro scientists
are really interested in is going the
other way so they want to they want to
choose a very specific brain region and
then they want to automatically learn
the tasks which act maximally activate
this and to sort of put this more into
more commercial context if you're sort
of doing where web design you want to
when you sort of change things in your
website and you deserve a be testing you
play around with the configuration of
your website and what you see is sort of
the churn rate or the bounce rate what
you actually want is you want to
maximize the bounce rate and
automatically choose these parameters to
do that right so this is sort of the
framework we were in and we're instead
of trying to maximize bounce rate we
were trying to maximize sort of brain
activation in a very specific brain
region and so we have a paper which is
it's actually open access so you can
download it and and what we did we chose
a very specific brain region and we were
able to sort of tune a very specific
task and sort of tune the hyper filers
of that task to sort of get maximum
brain activation in a certain region and
so we were quite excited that this
worked and we thought well okay since we
can do it for one task wouldn't it be
great if we were a bit more ambitious
and we did it for loads of tasks or
wouldn't be great if we took every
single task that was ever proposed in
sort of the neuroscientific literature
and we automatically search these tasks
in real time in a scanner so this is
this is where this sort of work came
from right we said what if we collected
the text of all the neuroscientific
papers that had ever been written and we
somehow studied these texts sort of
distill out the key tasks what people
have been studying and then instead of
you choosing a task you would choose a
specific brain region and then we would
automatically search these tasks and in
an intelligent way and to learn the task
which resulted in the maximum activation
and of course we're not the first guys
to think about this there is a paper in
2011 which sort of did exactly this and
and they went and they sort of collected
all the text for about 10,000
neuroscientific papers
and and in addition to the text they
also got the brain activations right so
for each paper you had all the text and
also you had in a standardized space the
brain activation regions the brain
regions which had been sort of
scientific as statistically
significantly activated and so this this
was like a great starting point for us
and we actually use we use pretty much
the same data set and if you want to
play around with this data set it's it's
a it's available for free so if you just
get a new your org you can download all
the text and all the corresponding brain
activation so instead of using the full
text we would just use the the abstracts
for each fresh paper which we thought
sort of contained all the relevant
information and so this is this is like
a sample entry right so here you have
you have an abstract or sort of the
first bit of an abstract and you can see
that this is a this is a task to do with
like episodic memory and it was a sort
of verbal associative and coding task
and I said these are sort of the
keywords will be looking for right and
and so these this is what will sort of
feed into our algorithm and to try and
sort of learn a hierarchy across all
tasks so so given given so sort of
10,000 and abstracts like this we wanted
to sort of end up with with two main
goals the first was to try to sort of
cluster documents together so documents
that are very similar or abstracts that
are very similar we want to put them
together and so inherent in this is so
defining some sort of distance across
documents right so and whilst the sort
of very intuitive notions for distant
with with the vectors when you're trying
to take distance across words it becomes
or across text it becomes a lot more
difficult right and because they don't
live in a standard Euclidean space and
so the traditional methods sort of fall
apart and so in order to do this what we
actually wanted and what the main goal
of this work was to sort of extract a
low-dimensional embedding or what people
sometimes called semantic
representations for each document and
that means effectively take each
document and map it from a bunch of
words into some sort of high dimensional
vector space which sort of lives in some
sort of euclidean space and then once
you have this you can take distances you
can measure similarity you can do
whatever you want so this was this was
sort of the crux of what we were trying
to do and and as hopefully I can
convince you today
also machines are one way of doing this
as there's a whole sort of NLP is a huge
huge rip a huge sort of area but both
machines are one way which you can do
this so i know that it's sort of a
Sunday afternoon and I don't want to
sort of get stuck into things without
sort of giving you some motivation to
where we're going and this is this was
sort of like what we were trying to get
towards right so on the left here you
have each dot and this plot is a it's a
document so it's an abstract for a paper
and and what we've got here is each
paper has been transformed into a high
dimensional vector space and then we
sort of shrunk in this back down into a
two-dimensional plot so that we can so
that I can show it here so you can think
of this is sort of putting each each
document into sort of some fifty
dimensional space and then I've just
done a slightly fancier version of PCA
to put this back down into a
two-dimensional space that you can see
here and and so you can see with that we
then ran some sort of really basic
clustering so I think I ran k-means on
this and you can see some clusters
forming here and and actually if you
then take the documents in that cluster
and see the associated brain activations
with those documents you can see that
there's a very clear patterns right so
if these clusterings were sort of
totally meaningless you would see sort
of activations here all over the brain
but what you see here is for example
cluster six here it seems to be
associated very clearly with the motor
region right so you see so you see the
motor areas and being flagged up so
going back to our sort of motivating
problem if someone wanted to activate
motor regions you might say okay well
I've got this cluster here which seems
to do that quite well you should try and
consider tasks that were describing
these documents here right or you know
if you looked at cluster 3 where you
sort of have the amygdala being
activated and you might say okay well if
you wanted to study that brain region
you might look you might just consider
these these are these documents here
okay so how did we get to this this plot
and so I want to start by talking about
restricted Boltzmann machines which you
can sort of think of the special case of
deep Boltzmann machines and then I'll
sort of move on but before I introduce
them I just want to make clear what
their advantages are right so both
machines are unique in that there there
there generative models so you're
actually learning a distribution over
the data and this is cool because you
can then sample you can then generate
samples or dream new new new em new data
sets right so if you learn a good
generative distribution you can then
generate more data if you wanted to
they're fully unsupervised which suits
our needs and and actually this this
fully unsupervised and aspect of them
both machines are often use a sort of
pre training for neural networks so if
you have if you have a small labeled
data set but a quite large data set
which is unlabeled you can sort of try
and learn the distribution over the
whole unlabeled data set and use that as
a sort of pre training and for that for
your supervisor task and so people
typically take both machines and stack
them together to sort of form deep
belief networks deep bulky machines
which sort of both machines with more
hidden layers and these these are quite
nice because you're able to learn
features of features so as you sort of
go higher up in your hierarchy the
things that the the features that are
being picked up by your networks are
sort of more abstract in them and this
is what sort of gets people excited
right because you're able sort of learn
really complicated patterns in your data
the disadvantages of both machines in
general are that training isn't
straightforward although in the case of
a restricted Boltzmann machine training
is is not that difficult and hopefully
I'll community that today and but the
main really big problem with Bolton
machines in general is that model
selection or or model comparison is
really difficult and because actually
you only learn things up to a
normalizing constant and then we'll
discuss that a bit but learning that
normalizing constant is is quite tricky
so Bolton machines are a special case
I'll start shooting bolts machines are a
special case of bawls machines which are
a sort of undirected graphical model
which help you learn a distribution over
your data set so if we assume we have
the visible binary units for now and you
want to learn a distribution of these
binary units you might assume that
there's some latent hidden units which
also affect their distributions are and
so what both machines let you do is they
let you learn very flexible models over
you're over your data set and the way
they let you do this is by defining
pairwise potentials across your hidden
and visible units now whilst you're able
to learn very expressive invert
flexible models because you have all
these paralyzed potentials across both
hidden in visible units training
Boltzmann machines is actually really
difficult and so in restricted Bolton
machines we sort of a restrict the
graphical structure and sets bipartite
so that all these dashed edges here are
sort of set to zero they're not allowed
to be in the model and what that means
is that and the visible units
conditional on your hidden units become
independent and vice versa and actually
this is what makes training both
machines really really straightforward
in practice so for now I'm just going to
assume that the visible units are binary
so think of these is sort of like pixels
in a black and white image and then I'll
discuss how you can extend this to sort
of text or or you know Gaussian visible
units and an actual fact pulse machines
can deal with sort of any exponential
family visible unit so they're very
flexible in essence so both machines are
parametrized by these these weights
right these weights specify the
dependencies across the units and so you
can think of these way to sort of
summarizing some sort of measure of
correlation across these units so if
this weight is large and positive that
means is if this visible unit is on then
it's going to really encourage this this
kidding unit to be on as well and so the
way learning works or in a both machines
you try you try to maximize the
likelihood over your your data set and
this is defined as the exponential of
your energy so these are sort of
statistical physics models and we try to
sort of try to minimize energy and and
actually we'll see in a second this
likelihood term is available in closed
form precisely because we sort of impose
these restrictions right so imposing
these sort of restrictions on the
graphical structure at least the two
sort of key and properties which makes
training bolts machines sort of somewhat
straightforward the first is the
conditional independence so given the
hidden units all the visible units are
conditionally independent so if you were
if you want to sample the visible units
given the hidden units all you would
have to do is sample each of them
independently right so this turns into
like selecting or sampling a bunch of
univariate random variables and so you
can do this really quickly
and easily and it's the same for the
hidden units so if you want to sample
one layer conditional on the other layer
this is this is very easy and actually
these distributions you actually have
access to in closed form and so recall
that each of the units is binary so it's
either on or off and so the distribution
of the of the if' visible unit
conditional on your head in layers is
just just a Bernoulli random variable
with this sort of probability of being
on right so in order to sort of sample
your visible units given your hidden
units or vice versa all you have to do
is sort of calculate at this sort of
input function or the activation
function and then and you just sort of
sample a binary random variable with
this with this probability so I mean if
you if you want to do this in Python it
will just be two lines right so all you
have to do is calculate so I'm given
some vector of hidden units you just
this this dot product at plates this sum
for all the visible units you then pass
it through your Sigma little activation
function and that basically squish it
sit down to between 0 and 1 and then all
you do is you sort of sample binary
random variables sorry Bernoulli random
variables with with this sort of
activation probability and actually this
is pretty much training researcher bolts
machines just boils down to doing this a
bunch of times and so so this is why
it's not that tricky so training so
since we training proceeds by sort of
trying to maximize the log likelihood of
your visible visible units right so
unfortunately at this log like if it is
really complicated ennis it's not closed
form so the weight training works is by
iteratively calculating the gradient
taking one step in that case in that
direction then crackling the gradient
again so this is in a gradient descent
framework now in the case of restricted
boltzmann machines at this this
derivative here so the derivative of the
log-likelihood respect to your
parameters W is a turned out to be the
sum of two expectations right so the
first of these expectations is with
respect to the distribution of the
hidden units given your visible units
and so this because of this because of
the the graphical structure of the
bottom of the restrict both machine you
actually calculate this in closed form
right so you can given some visible
units you can calculate the hidden units
in closed form the second distribution
is the one that causes some trouble
because it's based it's over the
distribution of the hidden and the
visible units simultaneously and
actually this this you don't know am and
this is what you have to sort of
approximate and this is why instead of
just being absolute maximum likelihood
is it's a proximate last moment so as I
said the first expectation you simply
sample the hit the hidden units given
your visible units and this is just a
bunch of Bernoulli random variables
again where you sort of adjust the the
activation for each one and and for the
second the second expectation you try
you sort of approximate this via mcmc
and basically what this what this what
it boils down to is you just sample the
hidden even the visible and the visible
given the hidden a bunch of times so if
you iterate this K times you actually
you converge the distribution to the
Joint Distribution but in practice doing
this for large K is quite
computationally expensive so people
typically do this for a small number of
first monomer loops and actually it's
been showing that k equals 1 which which
you know people that do MC MC will tell
you this is like a really bad
approximation but it's been shown in
fact that this sort of leads to give
them good good performance so so so
typically all you do is you just sample
the visible given the hidden and the
head and given the visible units and you
just take that as their as as you rested
so if you were to do this in sort of
Python it would just be a bunch of like
five lines of code right so the first
expectation you're estimating it here so
you just that you have the visible units
as your input and use calculate the the
sort of the activations for each of your
hidden units and then you sample them
and then you just take the inner product
this is your this is sort of the first
term the positive term and then in this
in the second term you you again you
then you sample the hidden units again
but given this sort of imaginary sample
of so you sample the visible units
giving this imaginary sample of hidden
units and then you sample the the hidden
units again and this is this is sort of
like one step in that in that iterative
process if you would if you want to do
this more times you could sort of loop
over here and you would get a better
approximation but it would be sort of
expensive and this difference here is
your your gradient step and so you would
sort of iterate this a bunch of times
until you got some sort of convergence
and of course one thing I want to make
clear is that the number of parameters
in this model is is huge right so you
you have one edge between each visible
unit and each hidden unit so the number
of parameters is is is actually lot is
larger than but it's of the order number
of visible units x number of hidden
units so it this can be like in the
thousands or in the in the millions if
you have a large a large network so it's
really important to sort of try and
correct for overfitting and so the the
simplest way of doing this in practice
is to just use what's called dropout and
what this does is it wrap it in your
sort of gradient descent steps it
randomly and drops hidden units so what
this encourages it means that the hidden
units should learn patterns in your data
and they should be robust to patterns in
your data they shouldn't be trying to
learn patterns across other hidden units
so you're trying to you try to remove
the dependencies across hidden units and
so actually implementing this is really
easy right all you do is at your at your
grade in the sense that you just
randomly choose a head and unit and if
you and if this unit is chosen then all
these way to sort of dropped to zero and
it's as if you had built a network with
just two hidden units instead of three
okay so so far I've been discussing how
to model sort of binary visible units
but in this example we want to model
text and so one way of modeling text is
to sort of treat it as if it was binary
so you could you could model the same
sentence the ability to bind information
blah blah blah you could model you can
model it in this in a sort of an
incidence matrix right where you would
have one here because ability is the
second word to appear and then there
would be zeros and all this work in the
rest of this column because this this
word has already appeared and and this
is good because it lets you model order
right so this this this representation
of the text maintains the order of the
texture and the downside is you've
actually you represent a sentence as or
a document as this massively large and
sparse matrix right so you have as many
roses you have words in your vocabulary
and as many columns as you have words in
your text but actually each each column
is only ever gonna have one nonzero
entry so you have you have massive
sparsely and
and if you were to treat each of the
entries in this matrix as a visible unit
then the number of parameters in your in
your bulky machine would be huge right
and actually the number of times each of
these units is actually switched on
would be quite small so this is this is
a really wasteful way of training a
Boston machine and so what people
typically do when the trial model text
is to just instead of sort of sort of
give up on the order so to sort of and
not model the order directly and instead
just model the the number of times the
word occurs right so you model the word
counts this is sort of like a bag of
words model and so this is a much more
parsimonious approach and and you sort
of don't have the sort of sparse matrix
but you sort of lose the ability to
generate ordered text and and this was
the approach we took here right so the
visible units and stop being binary and
they became counts right so this this
visible unit would correspond to the
number of times this word occurred in in
the document and so since since the
visible units are no longer binary their
their conditional distribution changes
but it's still it's still very simple as
which was called a softmax it basically
means you calculate the probability of
this word being chosen and then you
normalize for all the other words and
and so if you were to sample words from
this all you do is just as sample almost
a multinomial distribution with with
these parameters but everything else all
the other properties in training for the
bottom machines is unchanged right so
you can still train in the same way and
everything else is falls out so now the
extension to deep bottom machines so as
with our BMS you sort of have this
bipartite layer but now you sort of have
more layers of hidden units right so you
sort of build the hierarchy upwards and
so what sort of the top level units are
doing is they're learning
representations about your hidden units
which are learning representations about
your data right so this lets you learn
sort of really complicated their data
distributions and and again they're sort
of energy based models so so you have
these these these weight vectors which
sort of define the pairwise potentials
between so the visible and the hidden
and the pair what the other two layers
of hidden units and but training these
models is
somewhat tricky right because and again
the the the derivative of the
log-likelihood sort of decomposes into
to expectations and and the first
expectation is is actually M with
respect to the distribution of the two
layers of hidden units given you a
visible units and so you no longer have
this in closed form and so what happens
is you have to sort of approximate this
using sort of variational inference and
and actually what it boils down to is
you sort of say okay let me model each
of these hidden units as an independent
Bernoulli random variable and I want to
try and learn the the parameter for that
random variable which sort of minimizes
the distance between that distribution
and the whole distribution and what it
boils down to is just intuitively
applying the steps of the training of
restricted Boltzmann machine and then
for the second distribution we have to
take the joint distribution with respect
to all the units in our model and again
we have to use MC MC for this and so the
approach is somewhat similar to to the
bolts machine except you don't restart
the Markov chain at each iteration you
sort of you sort of maintain it and you
iterate forward and and there's this
sort of this sort of helps with the
whole burning issue so you don't have to
you would have to do so many steps ok so
what are the problems with these models
is because they're so complex and sort
of the the distribute or sort of the
properties of the objective function are
are that it's not convex and it's not
well behaved and there's loads of local
minima and so actually initializing the
model to a good sort of initial guess
for your parameters W is really
important so if you don't initialize the
weights properly you sort of you get
very bad performance and so pre-training
is quite a big thing in sort of neural
networks and especially in deep bottom
machines so this the most popular
pre-training algorithm is to just sort
of build your stack of restricted
Boltzmann machines upwards so you build
the first layer and then you would you
would take the data as input and take a
bunch of samples these guys and then
treat these guys as data to build your
next layer and and this this this gives
you sort of initial guess and initial
guess for what the weight should be
and you then take those weights and
apply the general and training I would
so back to the exciting stuff of
actually seeing results so the way so we
took the abstracts for about 10,000
neuroscientific publications so the
average length of each document was
about 80 words and we had a vocabulary
of a thousand words and then we trained
a we trained a deep pulsing machine with
two layers of 50 binary units each and
so yeah we did pre-training is described
with the standard training for
restricted Boltzmann machine with one
step of Gibbs sampling at each step we
use drop out where each hidden unit was
removed with probability point one so
what do we get so what we got in our
model is you had if you provide you
could provide an input text and this
would sort of sin if you and if you then
sent that text upwards into the bolts
machine you would get a you would be
able to represent this text in a sort of
high dimensional vector space right of
like sort of probability activations for
the top top level use so this is a slide
where we represented each word in our
sort of 1000 word vocabulary and this
high dimensional vector space and then
we just did some really simple
clustering on these words and you can
see that there's actually words with
similar semantic meaning are sort of
clustered together right so here you
have things to do with memory retrieval
the hippocampus is the brain region
associated with memory so one thing to
keep in mind is because this whole model
was trained just a neuroscientific
literature there's going to be a whole
bunch of small quirks which are only as
specific to sort of the literature so
this cluster is to do a sort of language
this one to do with sort of age and how
the development of the brain and here
you have a cluster to do with sort of
like disorders right so disorder
schizophrenia and some sort of syndrome
so you can see that the embeddings we're
learning for each word sort of makes
sense any and if you were to take
distances across these words then you
would get to sort of things that make
some sense and so what we have here
again is we've embedded each of the
words in this high dimensional vector
space and then try to sort of project
that down into a
into a 2d space to plot and it looks
like a bit of a scatter but if you zoom
in so for example here that in the top
top box you see that these are all words
to do with emotions so you have that are
happy sad and the amygdala which is the
brain region which sort of controls
emotion and on the left here in panel c
you have sort of the hippocampus which
is to do like recall and memory and sort
of memory working memory at least step
of things and over here you have sort of
a child and development and all these
other things so you can see that the the
word vectors that are being learned so
it make make some sense and another way
to check that these the models learnt a
good distribution of the data is to do
what's called a sort of a one-step
reconstruction so you provide you
provide a word as input you go up the
model you learn the hidden the hidden
units and then you come back down and so
you see what what words are sort of what
words are similar given the hidden
representation you've learned for that
word and so you should get words that
are similar right so if you if you give
it memory as input and then you try and
see the reconstruction were just sort of
memory working is here because working
memory is really popular task in
neuroscience if you were to change this
on a different text corpus I wouldn't
expect that and things like face you get
face faces so these sort of things sort
of makes some sense so the cool thing
about these models is that sort of the
hidden layers or discriminative right so
this is what people get excited about
that when you can actually interpret
what the model is doing and what it's
learning in a totally unsupervised way
and so in our case actually if the
hidden layers we found to be somewhat
discriminative and so they were sort of
picking up on topics in the literature
so what we did here is we sort of as
input we just we just activated one of
the hidden units and set all the other
ones to zero and then worked our way
back down the the Boltzmann machine and
what you get is you get that the units
are sort of specific to very specific
topics in the literature right so for
example if just the fourth unit was
activated then you get things relating
to age if just the 38th unit was
activated then you get sort of reading
or followed or language tasks right and
and so this is this is sort of quite
cool yep and finally we get to some of
the pic
which I showed you at the beginning
where each each document is sort of
clustered air here and we can see that
the cluster sort of represents some sort
of task specific things so that's
actually all I have thank you for
listening and questions okay but thanks
for your talk it was super interesting I
really like it I just had one question I
understand that if you want to find this
equilibrium and you have a really big
magnitude of connections you will take a
lot of much in time is it correct yeah I
mean so so this was a thousand visible
units and then two layers of 50 good
news which sort of by things that other
people do is really small and even so
like I trained it on this laptop but it
was like three nights of you know or
three days of melting the machine so
yeah it takes some time yeah okay and
then a second question related with that
if you want to scale that and maybe if
you wanted to use it with images is
there any way to do it or any parameters
you can do or something yeah so um if
you want to do is it with images it's
tricky but the good thing is other
people have done similar things and then
they've made their networks available
online so they've put all their weights
and stuff online so you could you can
download that and use that as a sort of
a warm start and so that go back to the
pre-training thing and people have sort
of put their pre-trained networks
available for free you can you download
those and then you use this as sort of a
warm start for your task and that that
sort of helps massively yet yeah more
questions
hi thanks for a really interesting talk
and I was wondering if we compare this
method to any other topic modeling
approaches like latent de Risley
allocation or something like that Thanks
I i personally didn't and so the reason
why we did this in the first place is
because the flexibility of Baltimore
she's and being able to model different
modalities of data so text and say
images at the same time that's what got
us into it right so here we've just done
it on text but the dream in this work
was to sort of do text and images at the
same time and that's something that with
lda you can't do without sort of
proposing of telling emo and but in in
the literature that people have done
comparisons between these models and and
they they're similar I I mean I I I have
a preference for this because I've
worked with this and I have words lda
but I yep they're very similar yeah
thank you i was just due to ask you a
similar question and he said you you
have model topics for papers in in your
science but how general is this more
this neighbor that you have bill do you
think you can catch this network bring
it to another topics in in science yeah
good question i would say probably not
right and because this has been trained
on the new scientific literature and if
you've ever tried to read a paper from a
different sort of literature you can see
that there's a whole different language
there right so for example here in the
sort of the reconstruction of memory the
second word is working right and this is
because working memory is a really
popular task but in any other literature
you wouldn't associate the words working
in memory together and so if you were if
you were to sort of trying to extend
this to a different literature I would
suggest I mean maybe you could I was
just sort of scraping the data again and
starting again yeah because i mean i
wouldn't expect this to generalize
further than this yeah that was what I
was about to say because I know about
the people that does cancer research
with they have computers that since the
literature of drug research is
among us they have systems to
automatically read the papers of new
drugs and then see which drugs may apply
to what kind of tumor I don't know if
you knew about that yeah I know it's a
big thing because a drug drug research
is tons of money goes into it and as you
say like the literature is just
exploding and no one can keep trapping
yeah yeah if you want more references in
the Bible Agra fury off of your thesis I
don't know okay more questions okay so
let's think the speaker for this right
you